[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la decisión de la corte suprema de eeuu
con respecto al aborto que ha sembrado
la indignación mundial nos acompañan en
este estudio para tratar la cuestión
matilde cartoon editora de la sección de
actualidad de la revista 'el bienvenida
gracias ante link montoya encargada de
la rúbrica de latinoamérica en el diario
le monde bienvenido angeline muchas
gracias y en dúplex del fin la come
socióloga y politóloga especializada en
género en centroamérica bienvenida
delfín muchas gracias el aborto tras la
decisión de la corte suprema en eeuu hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
[Música]
la corte suprema en los eeuu abolió por
seis votos a favor y tres en contra el
pasado viernes día 24 de junio la ley
que protege el derecho al aborto que
estaba vigente desde 1973 se trata de
una decisión histórica que permitirá a
cada estado decidir si mantiene o
prohíbe el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo es decir el
fallo del tribunal supremo señala que la
constitución no otorga el derecho al
aborto a partir de esta decisión se han
desencadenado la reacción y sobre todo
la indignación por un derecho que ahora
pierden millones de mujeres
estadounidenses vamos a analizar qué
supone la decisión y si hay que
enmarcarla en una corriente de retroceso
de derechos cuyo origen lleva tiempo
gestándose antes repasemos algunas
portadas diario boston globe el final de
raw que es como se conocía popularmente
por un caso a la ley que amparaba
constitucionalmente la libertad de una
mujer embarazada de optar por un aborto
aquí en francia liberación aborto el
viernes negro portada que se publicó el
día que se conoció la sentencia el cube
ganter national habla de la guerra
contra las mujeres dice la publicación
que la decisión provoca una onda de
choque a nivel en mundial bueno mattín
en que se traduce en la práctica la
decisión del tribunal supremo de eeuu
directa la consecuencia fue directa
hemos hablado con médicos en texas y no
dijeron que al momento de que esta
decisión fue pública publicidad fue
publicada entonces ellas tuvieron que
parar todo y llamar a los pacientes para
decirles que la el aborto no era posible
ni ese día la semana que viene ni nada
así que las consecuencias son reales y
al momento ya no se puede hacer en unos
nueves estados 9 y hay algún instituto
que habla de que pueden llegar a ser 26
si contabilizamos que algunos incluso
podrían llegar a esta situación durante
este verano exactamente si es lo que va
a pasar y lo que ya está pasando es que
hay unos estados que quieren que el
aborto ya se para pero hay unos jueces
que intentan parar en los tribunales y
hacer para ganar un poco de tiempo eso
es el caso en utah en florida en
luisiana y es una batalla una guerrilla
jurídica súper específica y muy porque
vamos a ver si esto se puede pasar a
la escalada del continente y encontrar
las mujeres porque además es clasista la
que tenga las posibilidades de hacerlo
podrá tomar un avión si está en un
estado que no lo permite cruzar eeuu
para hacerlo o bien de otras fórmulas
pero una señora imaginemos una latina
una negra que vivan dakota del sur está
condenada pero el problema es que por
ejemplo en luisiana al momento antes del
viernes pasado sólo había tres clínicas
de aborto imagínate luisiana es súper
grande así que ya era súper difícil y
ahora que lo están intentando pararlo lo
vamos a ver pero todo era muy difícil
tenemos también la píldora abortiva que
tú puedes tener en el a ver cómo se dice
en el mail y qué
exactamente lo que te lo pueden enviar
pero van a poner nuevas leyes y nuevas
dificultades para no tenerla exactamente
tremendo vamos a seguir luego hablando
del caso de eeuu el caso es que esta
decisión
un poco en contra de la corriente en
latinoamérica fundamentalmente en
américa del sur aunque en latinoamérica
hay que hablar de varias velocidades con
este tema si últimamente
desde el 2020 en todo caso hubo grandes
avances el principal primero y principal
ha sido argentina en diciembre del 2020
que ha legalizado el aborto hasta la
semana 14 del embarazo esto ha este
llevado toda una corriente digamos de
aperturas y de otros grandes países que
han tomado decisiones similares no
iguales pero similares como por ejemplo
en méxico y en colombia que han
despenalizado el aborto que no es
exactamente lo mismo que legalizarlo la
despenalización es simplemente que una
mujer que aborta no va a ir a la cárcel
pero este la legalización es que las
mujeres pueden ir a un hospital y se les
garantiza la práctica en los hospitales
pero bueno el hecho de que ya no esté
penalizado es un avance enorme y en
grandes países como méxico y colombia
a este supuesto un avance monumental
ahora hay otros países chile por ejemplo
están en ese proceso todavía no está
legalizado pero este está avanzado el
proceso
en otros países en cambio con américa
central al contrario la legalización del
aborto en argentina ha llevado a una
respuesta de los sectores conservadores
que hicieron que por ejemplo en honduras
en enero del creo que fue enero del 2021
o sea justo después de la legalización
en argentina este se grabó en la
constitución la prohibición del aborto y
del matrimonio igualitario también este
ahora hace falta las tres cuartas partes
de las votantes de los votantes de los
diputados para revertir esto o sea una
contrarrevolución aún más represiva a
partir de honduras ya es un país en que
el aborto está prohibido en todos los
casos incluso si la vida de la mujer
embarazada está en peligro luego les voy
a preguntar por esa especie de
contrarrevolución pero antes en dúplex
el recuerdo tenemos a delfín la con
socióloga y politóloga especializado en
género en centroamérica delfín qué
consecuencias va a tener el fallo de la
corte suprema en la región yo creo que
esto puede seguir estimulando y
legitimizando movimientos anti abortos
que ya son
fuertes al nivel regional
que tienen ya apoyos desde
fundaciones
muy adineradas
no solo potente en término político sino
que tiene muchos fondos como para apoyar
en marchas movilizaciones
en contra del aborto una de esa
fundación en la fundación human life
international que tiene muchas enlaces
regionales podría seguir consolidando
algo que no he dicho lo suficiente la el
clasismo el clasismo de estas decisiones
anti anti aborto
el aborto siempre está practicando
américa central y américa tanto de
ustedes en el mundo
y hay una
poesía muy
existente e impactante
en estas sociedades que penalizan el
aborto donde las que pueden permitirse
el acceso lo hacen discretamente y las
otras están condenado a la muerte
entonces esto yo creo que es importante
también subrayar lo entiende que esta
decisión hay que enmarcarla en una
corriente ultraconservadora
que va más allá y que a partir de ahora
tiene otros objetivos también en el
punto de mira como el matrimonio
igualitario incluso los métodos
anticonceptivos
sí por supuesto además que este
movimiento viene de los años 80 es algo
que durante el reaganismo fue muy
desarrollado cuando la está este
corriente evangélico se desarrolló y
entonces
pensaron en hacer en elegir como se dice
para elegir estudiantes de derecho para
después ponerles en el supremo en
tribunales si es tan orquestado y
digamos que la llegada de trans supuso
su máximo apogeo
y por eso tuvieron un montón de
candidatos para después ponerles aquí
así que camps es como la en el momento
cuando todo fue visible pero ya hace
como 30 años por lo menos que todo esto
está en sitio en plaza y por eso hay
tantas cosas que cambia ahora yo de
hecho en la época de reagan organizó una
alianza con el vaticano
estamos hablando de los años 80 este
justamente con una agenda claramente
conservadora y anti derechos contra este
el aborto en los contraceptivos este
incluso contra la investigación sobre
células madres sobre un montón de
avances y este siente incluso
científicos y este está esta alianza
digamos con el vaticano después se ha
desarrollado de américa latina y las
ongs antiabortistas que nacieron en eeuu
después tuvieron influencia en américa
latina y también se desarrollaron ongs
con esta gente en el fondo no creen que
esto es una batalla por controlar el
aparato reproductor femenino que es
el gran control que ha ejercido el
sistema patriarcal y que se siente ahora
amenazado por la lucha de movimientos
feministas y por supuesto las mujeres no
deben tener control sobre su aparato
reproductor se considera que o sea lo
que está en juego en la prohibición del
aborto no es tanto una cuestión
religiosa como una cuestión cultural
para preservar cierta jerarquía de
género y de clase también para los
sectores conservadores
las mujeres sólo se varón se valoran a
través del priísmo de la maternidad
es la base de la sociedad entonces no
puede dejarse esta decisión en manos de
mujeres que no tienen la capacidad
racional para tomar
este tipo de decisiones sobre su cuerpo
el final cambios de la historia del
sistema patriarcal hombres decidiendo
sobre el aparato reproductivo de las
mujeres sí pero también mujeres tienen
un papel en esto en esta decisión por
ejemplo e miconi board que estaba
elegida es un año casi dos y ella es
instrumental en esto y también hay
movimientos conservadores únicamente
femeninos como por ejemplo el movimiento
counter women for merca esas mujeres son
súper conservativa por supuesto muy
religiosas y además
perpetúan una visión del mundo muy
restrictiva y para ellas es algo que sí
como lo dijiste ahora que valoriza
muchísimo la maternidad como tu
identidad y para ellas esto es el máximo
que tú puedes obtener en la vida no es
ser conocimiento y por ejemplo en este
grupo de construmat for américas tienen
una pequeña banda para las más jóvenes
que se llama armada de débora que es una
figura de la biblia que fue un juez
etcétera y ella en cuando manifiestan
siempre van con esos
con todo esto
ecología bíblica y necesitan que poner
este mensaje en el espacio público es
algo muy importante no hay de o no hay
separatismo entre el estado y la que
modela la sociedad buscan este tipo de
corrientes
qué modelo de sociedad buscan implantar
porque incluso creo que también que esta
corriente christe quiere librar la
batalla contra los métodos
anticonceptivos
que es parte de lo mismo los métodos
anticonceptivos van en contra de la vida
que está construida este como a ver es
una vida
heterosexual
patriarcal que no tiene que salirse de
esos cánones y los anticonceptivos le
dan autonomía a las mujeres así que no
se puede tampoco dejar todo el control
sobre todo el aparato reproductor de las
mujeres
y todo lo que se desvía en el matrimonio
igualitario también se desvíe tendría se
desvía de todo lo que se desvía de esa
línea es completamente rechazado y es
completamente oprimido también sí sí sí
claro este
darse que mike pence que era el
vicepresidente de tam no podía quedarse
solo con su mujer y siempre la llamaba
mamá bueno es su mujer pero siempre la
llamaba así e incluso en espacios
públicos así que hay algo tan tan
incluido en sus mismos no hay algo que
este modelo de vida es en sí es lo que
propia verdad es que es tremendo vamos a
hacer una breve pausa en este punto y
enseguida vamos seguimos analizando el
trasfondo de esta decisión de la corte
suprema de eeuu aquí en primera plana
hasta ahora
[Música]
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
liberté égalité actual y t
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de las consecuencias de la
decisión de la corte suprema de eeuu y
lo hacemos combatir cartón editora de la
sección actualidad de revista el mi
compañera angeli montoya encargada de la
rúbrica latinoamericana del diario le
monde y del film la com socióloga y
politóloga especializada en género en
centroamérica en bailén lamentó la
decisión pero gente que el acusado de
ser un poco tibio con no ser más
enérgico criticando la decisión de la
corte suprema respecto al aborto y
mattín que es reversible es reversible
esta decisión o es muy complicado que lo
sea
a ver es que hay diferentes maneras de
verlo
en mi opinión en como cuatro frentes de
resistencia es el primero es
institucional por ejemplo puedes
imaginar que hay que traer más jueces en
la corte suprema porque esto no tampoco
es escrito en ningún texto así que es
algo por ejemplo efe de r durante dos
años treinta lo hizo así que es algo que
es una posibilidad era una posibilidad
para di lugar
a los más conservadores después el
jurídico esto se pasa a la escala de
cada estado
el color político de un estado se podría
es decir si la población joven de
estados que van a votar
en el caso de florida me facilita porque
hay estados que son muy claros pero
florida que podría cambiar es un switch
state no que lo llaman ahí tendría un
valor increíble que la gente joven fuera
a votar cuando se da cuenta que depende
de que la política depende de su voto
esto es otro frente es el frente
electoral pero el problema es que los
demócratas como lo dijiste ahora ya no
tienen como la dinámica que
las legislativas de noviembre eso no sé
cómo lo va a pasar pero también hay el
último frente que para mí me parece el
más importante y como en américa latina
es la calle porque hay que acordarse
como lo dijo a gloria steinem que es la
grande ensayista feminista una grande
voz lo dijo ayer tú pones la decisión y
el poder en las instituciones que
quieres poner en ellos quiero decir qué
corte tiene este poder porque el pueblo
quiere darle así que si en las calles si
hay algo si hay una movilización ya lo
podemos imaginar cambiamos algo al de
link de estos a ver mucho en argentina
fue la calle primero siempre la calle la
que llevó las decisiones después no
absolutamente en argentina claramente es
una victoria la legalización del aborto
ha sido una victoria del movimiento
feminista que empezó como o sea
realmente muy chiquitito empezó hace 20
años en realidad se más pero se se
conformó un
colectivo de ongs a nivel federal en
todo el país en el año 2005 ya empezaba
de antes la movilización
y era un pequeño grupo de mujeres sobre
todo mujeres que salían a la calle se
empezó a empezó a crecer ese movimiento
muchísimo y a raíz del movimiento ni una
menos que se creó en argentina del 2015
contra la violencia contra las mujeres
creció muchísimo más porque se integró
al aborto como una violencia contra la
mujer es el aborto perdón el aborto
ilegal este como una violencia contra
las mujeres creció muchísimo y está esta
movilización la calle ha sido la que ha
sido retomada después por los políticos
y en particular con la elección de
alberto fernández en el 2019 que
permitió que llegara al congreso y que
se legalizara en el congreso pero
realmente el movimiento social momento
feminista que se ve que de hecho en
latinoamérica es el movimiento social
más importante del movimiento feminista
hoy este junto con el movimiento
indígena campesinos
y realmente en eeuu puede llegar a ser
la diferencia el movimiento de la calle
al final de la tercera opción la de la
calle quizás el clavo ardiendo al que
agarrarse del fin la socióloga y
politóloga éste sale del género hablamos
antes de las diferentes velocidades con
mi compañera angelina con las que avanza
el continente porque en centroamérica la
ley la legislación es tan severa que no
hay que olvidar que la alianza entre
actores evangélicos y actores católicos
desde el mundo asociativo en el salvador
en guatemala en nicaragua ha sido una
experiencia muy importante para estos
grupos ya desde mediados de los años 90
cuando uno va a los archivos de estos
momentos en la prensa y de estos grupos
evangélicos y católicos sobre todo
católicos en aquel momento uno se da
cuenta que hay mucha de mucho
desplazamiento de la idea de rechazo a
la guerra de clase y el rechazo a la
supuesta
guerra de género entre hombres y mujeres
esto se ve muchísimos muchísimas
palancas discursivas de esta época hay
un realmente una
reconfiguración de este discurso después
de las de los intentos revolucionarios
en américa central y esto se ve de
manera muy muy agudo mucha gente
en estos diferentes países no entonces
este el factor de la convergencia y del
peso que ahora tiene el peso político
que ahora tiene los los actores
religiosos es incluso en su capacidad de
existir como grupo parlamentario por
ejemplo
como es el caso en guatemala tse de que
el tema del aborto que es uno de sus
prioridades políticas es muy muy muy ha
sido
uno de los motivos por los cuales está
en varios países la real está destacado
en una legislación muy severa el aborto
es una palanca para reconciliar
supuestamente con este discurso en esta
retórica ex
elites ex enemigo de guerras que bueno
que utilizan la mujer y el tema del
aborto como moneda de cambio no para
aceptar
poderes impactos patriarcal me recuerda
también se lo llevamos al caso de eeuu
como tras recoge esa bandera para llegar
también a llevarse cierta cantidad de
votos creen que esta ola fanática puede
llegar a europa o estamos mejor
blindados no es blindado recuerdo que
que países como francia que ahora se
está hablando del tema de llevar
constitucionalmente el derecho al aborto
como lo ven pero la cosa ya está mal en
europa sólo hay que ver a polonia por
ejemplo murió una mujer hace dos años
porque el estatuto legal era más
importante el del feto que el suyo y
entonces tuvo un problema durante el
embarazo y bueno murió la mujer fue
exactamente la misma cosa y erland ya
así que son países
son nuestros y entonces esto ya existe
aquí y en los países en que es legal el
acceso al aborto está cada vez más
difícil mismo en francia hay lugares en
que no hay clínicas para hacer abortos
no hay médicos que hacen abortos y hay
este mujeres chicas jóvenes que tienen
que recorrer 100 kilómetros para ir a
abortar en italia hay regiones enteras
en que no se puede abortar porque las
clínicas se han declarado esté objetores
de conciencia y no se puede abortar en
regiones enteras o sea que el acceso al
aborto está ya es esta dificultad o esté
en países en que uno pensaría que es un
derecho adquirido y que no hay ningún
peligro el avance este conservador el
hecho de que haya 89 este diputados del
asombremos nacional de la extrema
derecha en francia no es una buena señal
ningún derecho para la mujer y si está
adquirido nunca es igual de boba si
mantengo cualquier mínima crisis
política o de la entidad lo primero que
va son los derechos de la mujer y lo que
estamos viendo es lo primero que
pensamos en simón de jugar con él este
episodio
sí sí absolutamente tenía razón
el derecho al aborto puede estar
amenazado incluso en francia un país en
que uno pensaría que es un derecho
todavía en la mayoría de la puebla' de
la población está sigues estando a favor
del derecho al aborto esto todavía es
una cuestión este
realmente arraigada pero nada es
imposible también en eeuu hay una
mayoría sociológica según las encuestas
que está a favor si 70% de la población
considera que el aborto es algo es un
derecho que es que necesita continuar y
que necesita estar aquí así que por eso
es como estamos viendo en eeuu una
dictadura de la minoría como una jurista
grafía si lo puedo suponer así así
porque sólo hay nueve personas que
controlan 330 millones y una
configuración de 9 personas que se ha
ido tejiendo a lo largo del tiempo con
unas influencias con unos grupos de
poder y ccoo es por ejemplo está bueno
los nombramientos de ciu y van cambiando
todo quiero decir que dura hace dos años
el tema del roe no realmente no estaba
tan en peligro no en dos años todo
cambia por y durante esta noche esta
mañana leí que también están
modificando leyes para el clima tx para
el cambio climático y están
todo le lo está cambiando le vamos a
preguntar precisamente por ello a la
señora la comporte parecería que las
democracias en teoría debían proteger
los derechos de las mujeres lo estábamos
hablando tiene europa pero nunca hay que
darle nada por sentado sobre todo cuando
se habla de derechos de las mujeres ya
lo dijo simon de beauvoir hay
diferencias en cualquier caso en este
campo entre democracias asentadas y
regímenes autoritarios las democracias
nunca han sido garantías absolutas
de la protección de los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos de las mujeres
la democracia han nunca dé por cien por
principio disuelto a las jerarquías y
las discriminaciones de género no
siempre han sido precisamente
movimientos sociales que han abogado por
la igualdad y por la libertad individual
de las mujeres etcétera etcétera pero sí
bueno y el ejemplo de
creo que el ejemplo de eeuu es un buen
ejemplo para para mostrarte que estos
derechos son son reversibles
qué pasa ahora en los países donde este
giro hacia el autoritarismo se hace más
tajante no
como por ejemplo en el salvador en
guatemala y nicaragua todos tienen en
común el más allá desde la finalización
completa de todos tienen en común de
querer en regular controlar el mundo
asociativo
el caso más el ejemplo más
radical ahí es el caso de nicaragua en
nicaragua desde hace algunos meses ahora
a todas las organizaciones feministas
que han sido más dirigente para la
igualdad entre hombres y mujeres para la
diversidad sexual para demostrar que
había absolutamente que romper con las
leyes que criminalizan a las mujeres que
quieren abortar todas han sido cerradas
a y la inmensa dificultad es que hay una
represión
fuertísimo en contra del mundo
asociativo en general en nicaragua y en
particular desde hace años en contra de
las feministas el giro autoritario es en
estos 33 países al menos ha sido un
obstáculo todavía mayor fíjese que para
resumir un poco de lo que estamos
hablando hoy angeline el otro día leía
una el título de una tribuna en el
diario 'el país' que era muy muy simple
muy esclarecedor decía sin aborto no hay
democracia simplemente de hecho es este
un eslogan que
supongo que viene de argentina pero en
realidad bueno que decía que el aborto
era una deuda de la democracia después
de la dictadura este se garantizaron
muchos derechos el derecho de voto el
derecho a poder opinar tiene sus propias
opiniones políticas sin ser detenido
desaparecido torturado pero no estaba el
derecho de las mujeres a controlar su
cuerpo y estaba ese eslogan que era el
aborto es una deuda de la democracia y
si completamente es que no hay libertad
de las mujeres sin controles desde luego
no tengan dudas que si fuéramos los
hombres los que nos quedáramos
embarazados ese derecho ya lo tendríamos
desde luego no sería ridículo cuando las
cosas ponen a la inversa resulta
ridículo decir la verdad pues es lo de
siempre muchísimas gracias a las tres
así un placer compartir este tiempo con
ustedes ya todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana quien en primera plana
gracias
[Música]